Late Wednesday, after initially trailing,
a voter initiative appears to have been approved
to make Denver the first US city to decriminalize magic mushrooms.
And it's thanks to these people at this election night party.
We all know that this goes way beyond Denver,
way beyond Denver.
Right now this thing is a coast to coast movement.
Kevin Matthews is the campaign manager behind
Decriminalize Denver
the political activist group that got the
measure on the ballot.
He also personally testifies to the power
of psilocybin mushrooms
which he says helped cure his depression.
I was a cadet at the US Military Academy
and my life dream was to serve my country
as career army officer
and while I was at the academy I was diagnosed
with major depression
and then I eventually received a medical retirement
from the army because of depression
and it felt like that my purpose had basically
crumbled apart and disappeared.
Then I met an amazing group of friends here
in Denver who responsibly introduced me to psilocybin.
And it was this one experience that I had,
just cleared the fog,
and so after that experience, the benefits
lasted for weeks,
that really enabled me to step outside the
box of depression
and start to create a new life for myself
without needing to go back to using the mushrooms again.
Campaign political coordinater Cindy Sovine
brought her experience lobbying for increased
access to cannabis to the psilocybin mushroom fight.
If there is anything that this country should
be talking about after we do this in Denver
is that we have set the container to decriminalize
all drugs.
This is about harm reduction and we need to
start there
before we start talking about legalizing any
more
because we should not be giving people the
ability to make a profit off the sale of a legal product
while we're still putting people in jail for
using that product.
Denver police have averaged an arrest of about
50 people a year for the past three years
for possessing or selling psilocybin mushrooms
and prosecuted about 11 of those cases last
year according tot he Washington Post.
But Sovine says that while the numbers may
be small, the personal impact is huge.
If you are the mother or the son or the brother
or the father of one of those individuals
it is still a priority, in fact one of the
folks very much involved in our campaign
is one of those people who was arrested and
thrown in jail
and still to this day has ramifications within
his life
for what he can and cannot do because of psilocybin.
Sovine also says she believed Denver already
had the psychedelic culture
necessary to be the first to try decriminalization.
A culture which is on display in the city's
rhino art district
that features buildings and an entire alley
covered with psychedelic street art.
The psychedelics are already here, there's
already a psychedelic renaissance happening
we're seeing different types of providers
that are coming in
and now using this, Innate Pathways, MAPS up
in Boulder who are doing all these types of research.
There's a lot more information available here
in this community and locally around what's happening
and they're being used, they're being used
in the music scene they're being used all over.
We are looking at that and recognizing that
we don't think that people should be going to jail
or otherwise losing their livelihoods for
the result of using this substance.
Colorado was one of the first two US states
to legalize recreational cannabis sales
which it did by voter initiative in 2012,
putting it on the frontier of American drug policy then and now.
This is the best place to do this in the country
right now.
Denver and maybe the state of Colorado is
in many ways, at least with drug policy,
embracing more of this libertarian concept
that as long as I'm not causing harm to self or others
we should be, we should have the freedom to
use whatever substances we choose
and put into our bodies whatever we choose.
Denver's decriminalization initiative makes the possession or use of psilocybin
the city's lowest law-enforcement priority
and prohibit the city from spending resources
to impose criminal penalties for the personal use
and personal possession of psilocybin mushrooms
by persons 21 years of age and older.
and also establishes a panel to review the effects of the change in law.
It does not legalize commercial sales of mushrooms
leaving a potentially large gray market.
Sovine says her experience in cannabis
legalization,
which progressed from medical to recreational
in every state that's legalized it,
convinced her that decriminalization rather
than medicalization
is actually the far more radical and liberatory
path to take.
Maybe we want to see doctors being able to
prescribe psilocybin
but is that the only way we want to be able
to access it?
Should we still be going to jail and having
it be a criminal offense
outside of having a physician prescribe it
for you lawfully?
I think that the core tenet of the reason
why the campaign became what it was today
was because we don't necessarily think that
going through the process
necessarily means access to all patients.
Groups like the Multidisciplinary Association
For Psychedelic Studies or MAPS
have spent nearly 33 years funding the study
of psychedelics
for treating mental and emotional problems.
And that work is only recently reaching fruition
with the study of the psychedelic MDMA
to treat post traumatic stress disorder about
the enter the final phase of FDA clinical trials
and the organization is hopeful it will achieve
full approval for use in clinical settings by 2021.
Scientists like Charles Grob at Johns Hopkins
have also studied psilocybin in a clinical setting
and found a measurable decrease in death anxiety
in terminal cancer patients
dosed with the drug sometimes just a single
time.
Subjects reported being more engaged in
their lives,
getting a renewed sense of self and a renewed
sense of meaning and purpose
to the time they had remaining.
But advocates say the more radical decriminalization
movement
complements rather than undermines the work
of groups like MAPS.
Psilocybin, mushrooms, have the potential
to address
the five psychiatric symptoms that we're facing
as a country.
and those things are depression, anxiety,
addiction, PTSD and pain.
The research is amazing, it costs a lot of
money and takes a lot of time
and the fact that people are being criminalized
today as we speak
is a big motivation for why we're doing this
work.
On the horizon activists are working to put
statewide psilocybin decriminalization
on the ballots in Oregon and California in 2020.
Both Sovine and Matthews believe that what happened in Denver won't stay in Denver.
Part of the team from California is here tonight, they came out to support us.
And I know the petitioners in Oregon.
The best advice I can offer is find volunteers who are committed to this,
fundraising is key,
really respect and honor the research and the researchers
who have dedicated their entire lives to this work, they need to be a part of the conversation.
It starts by forcing the conversation
and protecting access, whether you're using this plant for a medical reason
or a spiritual reason or a recreational reason
you should not be going to jail or losing your children for it.